i remember the day like years ago when i
realized like one day like i will die
every human being in the history of
mankind has died and i realize that if i
don't move to israel if i don't make
aliyah i will regret it at 50 i'll
regret it at 40 i'll regret it at 35
and well that realization matched with
not wanting to sit on the sidelines and
also realizing that through my work i
have this incredible gift to actually be
on the ground here
um
it kind of pushed me out
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures
j ventures riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
hello welcome to 20 minute leaders this
is a really cool story by justin hyatt
the chief operating officer of nazion
aiming to accelerate israel's growth and
perpetuating social impact through
partnerships and meaningful projects
he has a very young leader that was only
28 who made an aliyah a year ago and
currently lives in tel aviv
previous to that he worked at the united
nations as a senior strategic consultant
for danny danon he used to give him tips
before meetings comments on his speeches
and had a major input in building
strategic plans
justin describes those years as the
proximity of power
[Music]
you know tell me a little bit about
about yourself today you're the chief
operating officer of the nazion you've
you've done some monumental work also
with a with the the israeli ambassador
to the un as a strategic advisor and
today you're you're working on on
creating continuing to make a positive
impact on israel through through
different channels different type of
strategy so tell me a little bit about
yourself and where this passion to to
work for israel in israel where all
that's coming from yeah
i came to israel for the first time in
2009 i was the first person in my family
to ever come to israel i always kind of
joke and laugh with my grandparents that
if only my ancestors went you know east
instead of west my life would have been
a lot easier but instead of leaving
russia and going to israel they came to
america
um and you know israel was always that
poster in a evil school you know class
that was kind of faded the kid in the
dead sea hebrew school is not the most
sexy thing in the world no one likes
hebrew school and so when looking back
i'm always like horrified at that chance
that i never came here because i made
the association with you know faded girl
from the 90s you know in a poster at
beaver school in the dead sea and in
hebrew school and that uh you know
thank god uh
take me back so you're you're saying
this poster the faded girl the dead sea
israel is not a not a place for
a young teenager to go to to have fun at
least in the
in this perspective
yeah i mean my first association with
israel was
learning about it from the least fun
place ever which is reformed jewish uh
you know either school where i was kind
of the class clown and kind of like the
head of a group of you know misfits and
then you know increasingly all the
friends i had in hebrew school became
increasingly less interested in jewish
life what they ever were right and
certainly less interested in israel and
then all of a sudden i go to israel for
the first time in 2009
and it's kind of before the iron dome
and it's a very different israel than we
have today and uh you know you come to
this beautiful place you you know you
fall in love with it as a tourist and as
a kid of course
and then you realize that the world's a
scary place and that you know
bad people want to hurt this place
and it kind of changes the way you think
and it and you just
you realize that you can't look at the
middle east and you can't look at israel
from the comfort of your suburban
american home and i think that that
stuck with me
i never really saw evil as a kid i never
really saw terror as a kid the closest
thing was uh the kid you'd live down the
street his parents mur his dad murdered
his mom
and he then he killed himself you know
that was the extent of my you know
quote-unquote dramas again it's really
pretty frightening awful yeah it was
really scary um but you know suburban
america in 1990s you know it's it's
pretty peaceful um
and then 9 11 happens and you're trying
to piece that together as a kid
and it's kind of the first experience
with terrorism which was so far away you
know i i grew up in baltimore and that
happened in the pentagon happened in a
field i believe in pennsylvania and then
of course in the twin towers and then i
remember my first image of israel was i
think it was 2002
um it was that uh the terror attack at
the bat mitzvah bar mitzvah the suicide
bombing
and you know i said of my parents on tv
i was always very curious what is that
what i mean
where is that you know and they said oh
it's in israel the floor fell through i
was like in third grade or so they
didn't tell me the true the entire truth
so my first image of israel was both the
the faded poster at hebrew school and
then kind of like terror and and really
awful images uh that i probably
shouldn't have seen as a kid and i think
both of those together really helped
informed my like broader perspective at
a very young age
and so
transitioning then 13 years ago you're
coming to israel
it's it's one thing to change
perspective and to
may perhaps get reacquainted with with
you know a culture or country but but
it's another thing to go and now
dedicate a career or dedicate years to
the mission of you know of supporting
that country so what what happened there
where where did that intrinsic drive
come from
yeah well it's from my perspective you
know it's really interesting uh the last
two not including the current but the
last two ambassadors of israel to the
united states were both american-born
and i've always been so fascinated uh
with like the american-born uh
ambassador um who has to give up his
citizenship you know and who says this
is the one is the land of my birth and
one is my my country and my homeland
and uh you know
um for me you know it's a really bizarre
experience obviously that um i'm not the
ambassador to the united states but for
me it's a really bizarre experience to
say that my home now is a place where i
have no family
um and uh you know
and and i think it's kind of this
constant pull
and torture that many oleam kind of face
and that they willingly face and i think
it in one way one i think it makes
israel stronger that you have people who
are willing to
not and not suffer but to to to have a
sense of pain being far away from family
but there's also something so striking
and beautiful about it and it creates a
great energy in the city and you hear it
in disingolf center disengage square and
habima when you hear french spanish
italian you know english you know
british people speaking english
australian people speaking english south
africans and uh for me at least you know
um i think making aliyah was very
different uh in 2021 than it was in 2019
and i think increasingly the center of
gravity of the jewish world
is is is shifting more and more to
israel and away from the you know the
power cities of new york and la miami
and dc they're still great but i think
in the coming years that
the center of the jewish world was in
israel the center of the action is in
israel and uh me and the dozens of
friends i have were also orlean we're
ready and eager to be a part of it and
then and then thinking back to you know
those two ambassadors i think there's
something intrinsic that we can offer um
israel that uh you know that as people
who see it from the outside but now live
within it and now are integrating in i
think there's a great energy there and
through my career which you know i'm
only been working six five years or
something trying to integrate that
energy and that perspective and that's
passion into
my work and
i once heard a great line and it was
don't do what you're passionate about do
what you're good at
and i kind of have this uh this struggle
with it because
what i am passionate about thankfully
i'm somewhat good at
but i'm really trying to focus on the
broader picture and the broader goal and
not always
what i'm good at
why do you think that your perspective
on in israel
and this is not a challenge this is
curiosity and why is your perspective
on sort of what's happening you're
coming from outside of israel how do you
see that different from somebody who's
in it right i mean
intuitively we can we obviously somebody
who's looking at something from the
outside sees something different than
the inside that's fine but in what ways
tangible ways do you find
your perspective is different than
somebody who's coming from the inside
yeah
that i get a very similar question which
for many people which is why would you
leave new york you know
israelis can't really fathom this
um
but you know i i think back there's a
few things the first of which my
hometown it's kind of like
a third
ultra
a third secular jews and a third kind of
conservative jews
and uh over covid and over the you know
the increasingly anti-semitic attacks
happening across the u.s i would drive
on saturdays and i would see you know
or orthodox people walking visibly
jewish and i would really think to
myself are they actually safe
are they safe in
in america are they safe in baltimore
and i don't want to have like a like
apocalyptic you know no they're not safe
they have to come to israel but
and then i and then i think about that
in comparison to like when i walked past
kabad
in tel aviv or i walked to shul in tel
aviv and or in jerusalem
and
i i do think that that
the security of the jews outside of
israel is significantly lower than the
jews the security of the jews living in
israel and i think it's something that
the american jewish community is
starting to wake up on the
jewish federation of north america has
been successfully lobbying congress to
increase funding uh federal funding to
jewish institutions you see new jewish
organizations with massive funding
coming out of kovid with the sole goal
of uh
investing in technologies and uh
applications that will protect trolls
from texas to california to new york so
i think it's
broader kind of security as a jew and
that contrasted with you know
yes but you're but whereas here it's the
security of the jewish state
you know and that comes with its own
threats and its own challenges you know
with the threat from the north gaza you
know terror in judea samaria like
like so
we can't i i came here because i i
thought i feel one it's where i'm safe
is that's a jew i came here because i
always connected with the story of
zionism and i didn't want to kind of sit
in the sidelines i didn't want to be
like a jew who just goes to a bunch of
conferences and galas like i did that it
was fine but
it's not really enriching enough for me
and the third is that like
i i think we die all we all die one day
and when we i remember the day like
years ago when i realized like one day
like i will die every human being in the
history of mankind has died like you
will not beat it george washington died
you know elon musk
could die who knows he could find a way
to to stay alive forever and it was a
really humbling moment a few years ago
and i said okay so
what what what if i don't do x what will
like i will regret why
and i realize that if i don't move to
israel if i don't make aliyah i will
regret it at 50 i regret it at 40. i'll
regret it at 35 and
that realization matched with not
wanting to sit on the sidelines and also
realizing that through my work i have
this incredible gift to actually be on
the ground here um
it kind of pushed me out also covet
health you know helped me think about
life
incredible that that's just a i mean it
also sounds like you really got in tune
with with what's important to you and
being able to ask those meaningful
questions and you've decided to
join nazion
as chief operating officer what what is
what do you do there what is the role of
this organization yeah actively how how
do you interact with him the day-to-day
yeah so we're one of the oldest zionist
organizations in america it was founded
by
immigrants in the early 20th century who
came to america and who you know didn't
speak english they were from hungary
they're from russia um they were from
poland and they needed like basic basic
needs um whether it was healthcare or
you know insurance all these different
things um so for a while it wasn't even
a non-profit in the early 20th century
then as
american jews rose to prominence made
money you know
seized the american dream um i believe
it was 1951 they established
venezian as a philanthropic entity and
they hosted these big galas with
president gerald ford joe biden was
actually an honorary as a young senator
um and they started doing philanthropy
in israel gave some amazing gifts to uh
organizations in their infant infancy
like magenta vita dome we gave the a
major gift to benezion medical center to
make it banatian medical center um and
basically in the right before the
pandemic because life works in
mysterious ways i get a call and they
say this rabbi wants to meet with you
and i was really comfortable in my job i
was working at a private other private
foundation and i meet with this guy uh
and it right before the world shut down
and right before our lives forever
changed
and we were talking for three hours
um about what we wanted to build in the
jewish world in america and what what
what don't we like about the current
jewish world it's easy to complain
but um
you know we we were talking about like
what is our dream organization and how
could we build it little did we know
that there was a tsunami approaching
which was coveted um i think i had
covered at that dinner i think i gave it
to him or the flu or something so um we
meet in like uh mid-february um by
mid-march i'm working for the
organization and all of a sudden you
know organizations are closing their
doors organizations are are starting to
think about merging certain think about
how they're going to fundraise our
organization thankfully has a pretty
sizable endowment that it will keep us
uh more than alive and able to be active
philanthropically for many years to come
but it was a great moment of thinking
about what are we doing
what are our goals and what can we as
the youngest leadership team
uh in the jewish world
um you know i'm 28 he's 36
um you know if if friends of mine can
have startups or companies and and
manage you know hundreds of people
surely jewish organizations can be run
by people under 40. and so now we're
putting that all into action through
various projects and initiatives both
philanthropic dealing with new media
dealing with the size and scope with a
specific focus on creating partnerships
and relationships with our friends and
allies and other faith communities
focusing on major tick-tock influencers
focusing on major instagram
celebrities um later this week we have
an nba player with two million followers
landing in israel for the first time um
i can't say it it will be public it'll
be known when this podcast comes out who
that is but this isn't if you tell me
yeah exactly um but it's not so
complicated but uh we're scrappy enough
to get to the right people to get to the
people with millions of followers bring
them to israel not for some hosh podge
you know has baractra because frankly i
i
does it really work you know but to
bring him as an individual to bring him
who he's a devout muslim to bring him
for an experience to the country that he
already is interested in and he's not
interested in israel because of cherry
tomatoes
where the iron dome he's interested in
israel because it's a real place with
real people and a story that we need to
tell and we need to tell authentically
and we need to tell without it being
like on the defense all the time
and so that's what we're doing and
hopefully this is the first of many
trips that we will do um with our own
flair with our own chutzpah you know
whether it's uh whatsapp being the us
ambassador to israel asking for a
meeting or whether it's getting a future
or current prime minister to meet him um
you know a lot of organizations kind of
over bureaucratize and we're really
trying to run like a startup um as much
as we can and trying to use that energy
and hunger
to really achieve great results and just
the last thing i'll say is a lot of the
reason why a lot of organizations in
america stagnate and kind of just copy
paste step and repeat and don't really
you know make bold
entrances into their into their you know
focus areas is because they're so scared
of their boards and scared of kind of
like um presenting to uh to
presenting to their board about ideas
that may or may not fail thankfully we
have this great gift of not only a
sizable endowment but also a great gift
of a board that is willing to take a bet
on millennials to do exactly what they
should be doing which is dreaming big
which is looking at the issues not
looking at you know what donor will give
us x or y and hopefully the payoff will
um
will be huge and the payoff will make it
worth it and i think that's the kind of
energy and organization i want to work
with because some days will fail and
some days will succeed and uh
you know it's
two million followers you know hopefully
if we uh if we succeed we succeed big
and hopefully if we fail we fail very
discreetly
it's um
you know you mentioned something
interesting that a lot of our you know
you're a lot of organizations are over
bureaucratizing it and you're treating
it as very much as a startup you're
very scrappy very quick you know lots of
things the different different people
and is that i mean that is type of a new
behavior from this type of organization
right traditionally these organizations
are led by older people older
generations much more i guess a
proper and
student thai type of relationship here
you're saying there's actually a new
generation of of of
advocates for telling the narrative
telling a story and this is why this may
work
yeah exactly i mean look um there's some
great organizations run by people over
50 and and sure i i get it i understand
but in terms of the mid and smaller
organizations i think it's uh i really
commend you know our board who had the
foresight envision to invest in people
not for how old or experienced they are
though we're both pretty experienced but
really for the vision that they have and
their passion to to make a name both for
themselves and most importantly the
organization
and by the way we you know as an
organization we already have a pretty
strong name in israel
foreign medical center in the heat of
covid in uh january 2021
we funded uh yad rosa which is a new
well not so known anymore national care
center for holocaust survivors in haifa
and we were scrappy enough to get it on
the front page on the wa of the
washington post on holocaust remembrance
day
and you know uh many
we got it by being scrappy we got it by
acting quickly we you know you there's
certain things in life that you can't
outsource to other people and that you
just have to take and run with and uh it
was a really proud moment for us and a
great moment for us to realize that yes
we can achieve great things and uh
because we got on the front page of the
washington post millions of americans
read about the work of uh yeah the rosa
the work of the nazis but also
learned about the holocaust and learned
about holocaust remembrance day uh in a
way that wasn't passive and
and sad so it's certainly sad and
challenging to see holocaust survivors
who have urgent needs but in a way that
is proactive that a way that's saying
that we're yet we're remembering but
we're also caring for them and i think
many people
would be shocked especially in america
would be shocked to know would be
shocked to know how many holocaust
survivors in israel there currently are
and
horrified to uh to see how they're not
really being cared for the dignity that
they deserve
and uh
you know the work continues we still
support this amazing organization in
haifa um every month and we're looking
to continue and grow that support and
it's a lot easier to bring in other
partners when you have the verifi you
know the washington post uh you know
cheering you on on the front pages but
this is just one small part of a larger
picture of scrappiness of dreaming big
of thinking about scope and scale
whereas many organizations because they
look to only serve the jewish community
in israel or in america and only to
engage you know american jews which are
you know
it's very expensive for a marketing firm
to
to pinpoint a jew in new york you know
whereas through
certainly through embracing tick-tock
and embracing instagram it's not very
hard for us to engage millions of people
if we can engage the right people and
the right creators and celebrities and
if we could show them that uh you know
we're worth partnering with which we've
been pretty successful thus far so
hopefully it continues
justin thank you very much for all the
great work that you're doing um very
inspiring very inspiring also story for
how you got even got here and the
intrinsic motivation that is bringing
you to this and it's felt and the
innovativeness is felt the the young
nature of it is felt uh but also the
professionalism so thank you very very
much and best of luck with all these
endeavors and more and thank you for
being here
thank you so much
thank you
[Music]